take a break from building your snowman
because for the first time in forever
we're doing a theory on frozen
hello Internet welcome to film theory
you know the frozen lure you thought you
knew well prepare to let it go because
today's theory will change everything
you thought you knew about the adorkable
Anna and the incomparable adele dazeem
now Disney Animation has picked up a fun
little habit in last few years of
dropping hidden Easter eggs throughout
their movies making it seem like some or
maybe even all of them take place in a
larger connected universe and with
frozen being the biggest animated
moneymaker in well ever they've
connected frozen with a whole bunch of
other movies there are plenty of
theories floating around about the
Little Mermaid and Tarzan but the
connection I'm most interested in today
is between frozen and tangled and before
you run away thinking that you've heard
this one because of course there's stuff
on the internet that connects tangled
and frozen hear me out because this is a
brand new finding that I think is gonna
change the way that you see these two
movies yes there are movies about
long-lost magical princesses but the
evidence across Bowl points to a huge
secret about the relation between Anna
Elsa and Rapunzel's specifically that
Anna and Elsa aren't the sisters in
these movies that's right Anna and Elsa
not sisters I mean is that really hard
to believe look at the family portraits
one of these things is not like the
others
someone looks a whole lot like the
milkman nope it's not Anna and Elsa who
are the sisters but rather Elsa and
Rapunzel and sure you may be shaking
your head now but the backing for this
theory is real from the movie's lore to
Disney's own information and if you
stick with me I think you're gonna agree
the first pieces of evidence we have
come from Disney itself who've slipped
bits and pieces of information about
frozen's lore since the movie came out
first
frozen writer and director Jennifer Lee
confirmed a huge point in a reddit AMA
about king and queen king and queen what
are their names
ignore in Iduna really Scandinavia we
need to talk about your naming
conventions here in any case with Hagen
R and Iduna or lost at sea they're not
going off on any old 3-hour tour they're
sailing for a wedding it was also
confirmed that this isn't just any
wedding they're going to it's Rapunzel's
wedding from the end of tangled that's
huge right there we already have a solid
connection between the movies in two
ways
space and time looking at a map this
makes total sense based on where these
movies take place it's been pretty well
established that frozen's location of
arendelle is a hybrid of arendelle and
Bergen Norway it's so well known in fact
that the Norway zone of Epcot was
completely overrun after the movie came
out and Disney had special frozen tours
set up in Norway to handle all the crazy
Elsa fans storming into the country
probably the only time in Disney's
history where people actually were
excited to go visit FK tangled is likely
to take place around the corner just
across the North Sea and modern Germany
in a fictional city called Corona this
matches where the Rapunzel story is
originally based since it was one of
Grimm's fairy tales so they're
definitely close enough to bump into
each other out on their royal yachts or
royal ice barges I guess I don't know
what you guys do that far north we also
know when they connect in time based on
the hints Disney has already dropped we
know that these movies are three years
apart closer than any other Disney
Princess timeline we start with extra
scenes at the end of tangled where
Rapunzel and Flynn get married and start
their happily ever after we know at this
point that ogner and a dune are supposed
to be on their way to a wedding
Rapunzel's wedding but they never make
it when the main story of frozen starts
were specifically told that it happens
three years after the shipwreck which
means exactly three years after tangulls
wedding what's fascinating is that this
timing plays out both in the movie and
in real life at the same time in the
movies releases themselves tangulls
release was november 24th 2010 frozen
was released almost exactly three years
later to the day on november 27th 2013
and picks up exactly three years later
as soon as you start the movie the
timelines follow each other both in the
real world and in their own universe
which is brilliant and also not by
accident we know based on the wiki's
that Rapunzel is 18 after her movie she
gets married shortly after she shows up
back at the castle despite the fact that
Flynn says it took many years after
years and years
ask if you need proof for that Rapunzel
already says that he's lying in that
line if the wedding were to take any
longer than that Rapunzel's hairs would
have grown out and sadly Adelaide
wedding would also mean that Pascal
would not be in the wedding party he'd
be dead based on the average lifespan
for veiled chameleons sorry man it's
called the circle of life
so Rapunzel is 18 at the wedding and
when frozen happens three years later we
know Elsa to be 21 in short some simple
math tells us that Elsa and Rapunzel are
the same age and I mean exactly the same
age they were born at the same time
they're twins fraternal not identical
obviously but now I know you're saying
that that's just ridiculous yes the
movies are connected and yes they
overlap and stuff but it's impossible
that the two are twins right it's wrong
in fact it's completely possible to
prove it I'll start with some good
old-fashioned biology loyal theorists
know that some of my favorite theories
here a nun game theory are backed by
genetics and this one is no exception
one of the reasons people usually assume
that Elsa has to be the daughter of
ogner and a Doudna is that her eyes are
blue just like her mother's now the
genetics around eye color are slightly
more complicated than we were taught in
eighth grade science class but to
roughly simplify to prove the points
both blue eyes and green eyes are
recessive so you must have two light eye
alleles to get a blue-eyed kid when one
parent has green eyes and the other has
blue like you see in frozen the odds of
Anna Elsa individually having blue eyes
is 50% yay for the recessive
Scandinavian gene pool but it's just as
genetically likely for Elsa to belong to
the king and queen and tangled who for
the life of me I couldn't find their
names
turns out ignore Anna Doudna aren't the
only ones with blue and green eyes king
and queen tangled are yet another blue
and green eyed royal couple weird
coincidence right maybe maybe not at the
very least this means that genetically
they have the same probability as the
frozen royal couple of ending up with a
blue-eyed baby like Elsa but that's not
all beyond eyes we can also tell they're
twins based on the fact that they're
both left
handed 22% of twins are left-handed
which is more than double the world
average for Elsa we see her doing the
most important things in the movie as a
lefty her primary ice shooting hand is
left she creates Olaf with her left hand
touches her face left unties her braid
left and even tries to save Anna with a
crucial left-handed ice attack it's a
pretty similar story over on the tangled
side
Rapunzel is definitely more ambidextrous
than Elsa's and she does things with
both hands
however she shows a preference for her
left hand in crucial activities
especially ones where she has to act on
instinct she paints and brushes her hair
both with left and right hands but in an
emergency she brandishes her frying pan
with her left hand or bats lefty with it
she naturally reaches out for her
parents Lantern with her left hand holds
candles with her left holds Pascal left
and throws left and just so you don't
think I'm playing favorites other
characters are distinctly right-handed
in frozen Anna always knocks
right-handed and reaches out with her
right hand entangled Eugene swings his
sword right points right and touches
Rapunzel's face right-handed but all
this left handedness has to come from
somewhere right or left one of the two
luckily it happens that mommy tangled
happens to be likely left-handed we
don't get a lot of camera time with the
kings and queens in general but
Rapunzel's mother is shown with a
left-handed preference in most scenes
she's in holding Rapunzel left-handed
gesturing left-handed and reaching out
to touch Rapunzel left-handed after
seeing her for the first time in 18
years there isn't enough evidence on the
frozen side to say whether Ragnar and a
Doudna are left-handed or not but we
know the genetics lineup for tangled and
finally we have hair honestly none of
these parents are likely to produce
children with bright blond hair like
either Rapunzel or Elsa but as we learn
entangled Rapunzel's blonde hair comes
from the magic her mother absorbed from
a bright yellow flower if in fact these
two are twins it would also explain
Elsa's unusually vibrant blond hair
which is surprisingly more plausible
than the slim genetic chance of Doudna
and ogner have of producing a towheaded
ice princess so at this point the
location of the movie timing of the
movie and biology of the movie
support Rapunzel and Elsa being Disney's
true first magical princess sisters but
what about the really exciting stuff
what about their actual magic if these
two are indeed twins like I'm saying
they are they should have the same
powers right don't know if you've seen
these movies lately but ice blasting
definitely not the same as old healing
hair over here well hang on to your
anthropomorphic reindeer because there's
even more evidence to this theory first
of all it's really important to
reiterate the fact that Elsa and
Rapunzel are the only two princesses to
ever have magical powers in a Disney
movie seriously the only two princesses
in the eighty year history of Disney
films who can use magic that's pretty
incredible if you think about it and
it's not an accident this doesn't happen
just because they're cool Northern
Europeans who share the same magical
universe it's because they share the
same magical mom like I said before
Rapunzel absorbs magic from a healing
potion or mom drinks before she's born
this is how we explain Rapunzel's magic
for the rest of the movie and for better
or worse it kind of makes sense the
writers clearly took the time to build
in a backstory that justifies her magic
instead of it having to come out of
nowhere so where's the backstory in
frozen
where's our magical history lesson is it
laziness
well no this is an animation team who
bothered to draw in Snow White and
Sleeping Beauty into Rapunzel's book
collection if they left something out
it's because there's another explanation
no one in the frozen royal family has
magic or was ever exposed to it these
are the muggle iasts Disney characters
out there even when the royal family
takes Elsa to the rock trolls a ganar
can't answer right away whether else it
was born with magic or cursed with born
with the powers of coached born what an
oddly specific detail you've included
there Disney but this is the reason when
ogner stutters in front of The Rock
trolls he's showing a natural reaction
was she born with these powers uh yes he
doesn't know because he wasn't there
when Elsa was born with magic ever
wonder why Agner and Adina never show
any surprise about Elsa's magical powers
like when you just find it a little bit
startling worth a trip to the
pediatrician at least we never see them
doing normal things you'd expect parents
to do in the situation if they don't try
to cure Elsa they don't even seem to
look for answers about where her powers
came from don't you think that's a
little bit
strange well it's not if you consider
that they already know where her powers
come from her real mother the same that
gave Rapunzel her powers okay enough
beating around the bush let's actually
talk about that magic what a frozen's
biggest criticisms leveled at it from
honest trailers to cinemasins is that
else's power set has always seemed a bit
weird meet Elsa a manic-depressive
princess with a confusing set of powers
like creating wife Karen I think so they
kind of gloss over that one yeah she
freezes stuff causes major destruction
and blizzards builds ice castles all
that but then she also brings things to
life creating sentient creatures like
Olaf and marshmallow literally it's all
over the place
at first it actually seems like else and
Rapunzel have opposite powers with Elsa
stopping everything from growing and
Rapunzel making everything new and young
again a yin and yang sort of situation
but if you look closer their powers are
actually more similar than you think
let's go through it in the ending to
both movies the princesses save someone
they loved frozen it's Anna and
entangled it's Flynn or Eugene or
whatever his name is to start both
scenes the true love character saves the
princess
Eugene saves Rapunzel from Mother Gothel
and Anna Saints Elsa from Prince Hans in
doing so they both die in the process
onna by freezing and Eugene with a stab
wound onna exhale tsar last breath
Eugene falls limp these guys are gone at
this point each of our power princesses
literally hugs the true love for an
awkwardly long minute of sobbing and
then suddenly discover a new power they
never thought they had the exact same
power reviving the dead giving things
life entangle it's giving Mother Gothel
and Eugene life in frozen it's giving
snowmen and Otto life coincidence
not a chance it's the exact same power
executed the exact same way their powers
aren't opposite in fact they're twins
just like the princesses themselves Elsa
did inherit the power to revive things
just like Rapunzel she just also ends up
with some nice ice upgrades in short
everything in these movies from the
setting the background the lore the
genetics the magical powers even
structure of their own stories are
direct parallels so now I ask you look
at the evidence and look at the story
one more time through a new lens once
upon a time in Corona a kingdom in
northern Germany a sick Queen drinks a
magical healing potion made from a
magical yellow flower right before
giving birth she has twin daughters the
girls are blond as both are infused with
the magic of the flower one daughter
immediately demonstrates magical healing
powers when you sing and the other one
really seem to do all that much
mother Gothel discovers that baby one
will keep her young forever but she
can't just snip some hair so she has to
take the whole baby which she does by
kidnapping her and locking her up in a
tower king and queen tangled her heart
broken that baby one is stolen and they
realize they can't risk losing baby too
if she's ever discovered to have magical
powers they know Corona isn't safe and
send baby 2 on a trip across the North
Sea to the neighboring kingdom of
arendelle to live with a ganar in a
Doudna far away from Mother Gothel in
arendelle the king and queen eventually
realized that elsa does indeed have
magical powers too unprepared to raise a
magical child they try to hide Elsa's
powers to protect her from being
kidnapped like her sister Rapunzel
closing up the castle limiting the staff
hiding Elsa in doors it's to keep the
word from getting out to Corona that
there was another princess born with
magic and to protect their own daughter
Ana from accidentally spilling else's
secret or becoming the target of a
kidnapping herself they have her memory
wiped the bad rap ignore Ana Dunagan is
all in the name of helping to keep Elsa
safe until her sister Rapunzel reappears
and eventually the two find each other
when Rapunzel ends up in arendelle at
the end of frozen so is that the true
origin story of Anna Elsa and Rapunzel I
guess we'll have to see what happens in
frozen 2 but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and cut